[Musik]
vielmehr ist der punkt sich auf dem weg
zum spital wirklich diese stuhlgang art
tagebuch leben im alter brauchen ist und
gemerkt hat
all das und ich bis jetzt gemacht
angeordnet meine hobbys alles und ich
bin immer da und ich mag sie be- und ich
hatte einem sie robin rehmann hat
colitis ulcerosa ist chronisch entzündet
und dieser film wird auch kein happy end
haben denn die krankheit ist unheilbar
wie lebt ein junger mensch mit der
aussicht für den rest seines lebens
krank zu sein
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wie zb angst vor dem was ich daraus ja
das geht tatsächlich zudem ganz neue
neue lover sondern laufen mittelfranken
habe ich hatte zwar 2 weil ich bin mega
high mit colitis ulcerosa krampfer haben
oder wie man wohl sagen
und so hat seinem machen dann freut und
ja natürlich einfach zu viel gemacht
auf der einen seite habe nicht
schlachten und so was ich bin nicht
sagen dass es uns im notorisch es hat
schon immer früh zeichnete
aber es gibt auch nie nach krankls
straflager steffen muss sind viele
faktoren stress sei lang nicht oder
schlecht jährige lang geht und das ist
nicht so dass man jetzt wirklich so nach
rang für die internet quasi sicher
natürlich auch genetisch muss man
einräumen so nach krankheit entwickeln
und ich muss sagen es gibt mit viel
willen verrückten und leute mit krank
entschuldigung wenn du für den salon
abschalten ja in guten zeiten muss der
zürcher sechs bis achtmal am tag aufs wc
in schlechten sind es über 30 mal
[Musik]
früher war der 36-jährige der mann fürs
rückte bei verschiedenen radio und
fernsehstationen
[Applaus]
party exzesse und immer vollgas der
überdrehte selbstdarsteller landete beim
schweizer fernsehen eine steile karriere
auf der überholspur
vor fünf jahren war das wilde leben jäh
vorbei
robin rehmann wand sich mit krämpfen auf
dem wc boden er stand am abgrund
ich setze sei ein wichtiger ort wurde ja
also das wc stehen bringt mit chronisch
entzündlichen darmkrankheiten sehr sehr
viel sich auf dem wc und ich zusammen so
wie es spirituelles erwachen das komisch
aber es geht die wand zu sich selber
finden also die jacobs mag und sie die
hingegen wir die medizin oder so und ich
sagte so eine schwere chronische kranke
das ist richtig so servus team alltag
und bringt sich so einen anderen punkt
und du musst dich so intensiv mit tieren
mit dem jetzt beschäftige das dass der
jakobsweg ersetzt also dass er den
jakobsweg
ja das ist natürlich denken also dass
das wc sitz das sind das in blutigem
stuhlgang das ist konnte so beschrieben
wie beim slalom an darmkrebs
in der schweiz leiden über 16.000
menschen an einer chronischen
darmkrankheit
und sie alle haben etwas gemeinsam man
sieht ihnen die krankheit nicht an
darum hat sich robin rehmann entschieden
das tabuthema offen anzusprechen so
könne er anderen betroffenen vielleicht
mut machen mit der krankheit allein ist
das macht man alles viel schlimmer aber
ist es nicht gut wenn man also krankheit
zum lebensmittelpunkt und inhalt macht
das versagen seiner krankheit wird zum
lebensmittelpunkt
colitis ulcerosa ist eine
autoimmunkrankheit robin rehmann körper
bekämpft den eigenen dar
die ursachen sind bis heute nicht
restlos geklärt
um das ausmaß der entzündung zu
kontrollieren muss robin rehmann
regelmäßig zur darmspiegelung das spital
gehört längst zu seinem alltag erlebt
vernünftig ernährt sich gesund trinkt
keinen alkohol mehr der einzige rausch
der ihm geblieben ist sind die
flüchtigen sekunden des glücks wenn das
anästhesiemittel seine wohlige wirkung
entfaltet dies macht variante 2 würde
die ganze eu haben den argumenten der
versehrte rebell zelebriert diese letzte
subversion und die rauschwirkung
möglichst lange bei bewusstsein genießen
zu können will er etwas kompliziert das
erzählen
colitis ulcerosa chronisch entzündliche
darmerkrankungen kick wo der
neurologischen station in der
bezirksklasse alte speziellen mit kommt
ein pferd ehepaar sagt der barkeeper
sagt der barkeeper der barkeeper ins
gesicht
also grünlich schicken wir unsere
patienten an der stelle sich zu
entspannen wird noch witze zu erzählen
in angespannter halter kann ich noch
hinten
meine grings simone sind abdul und das
ist das nur ein mal im monat
alle einmal im jahr ein leben das ist
bei 25 die darmspiegelung macht der
spezialist für colitis ulcerosa am
universitätsspital zürich
die hoffnung dass es sehr gut ausschaut
ist leider war leider nur hoffnungs sehr
gut deutlich entzündet
die untersuchung ist fertig ist alles
erledigt auch besondere sucht ja das ist
so schade
die letzten zwanzig zentimeter sind noch
ordentlich entzündet aber da muss man
sagen da könnten jetzt wirklich mit
einer schau im einlauf therapie noch mal
versuchen was zu verbessern
robin rehmann wurde mit den jahren
zwangsläufig selbst fachmann für seine
krankheit nicht so gut schmeckt ja
wieder mal das bild im wahrsten sinne
des wortes das ganze vorbei und den
weißen wir ja es ist die ganz dick
findet sich jetzt nur noch ein teil
und das hat er wirklich schon viel
schlimmes gesehen und dienstag in berlin
darum danke das ist leider nicht möglich
meter gestutzt und sich weiteres thema
ja
[Musik]
viele chronisch kranke müssen ihren
angestammten beruf aufgeben oder werden
gar von der iv abhängig robin rehmann
hat glück er ist zu 60 prozent
arbeitsfähig und konnte seine stelle bei
virus dem jugendradio von srf behalten
nur live moderieren kann er nicht mehr
so oft muss er unversehens aufs wc
rennen sein eigenes schicksal cup in die
idee für eine sendung die er wöchentlich
aufzeichnet er gibt menschen mit
chronischen oder psychischen krankheiten
eine plattform herzlich willkommen ps
regierungs herzlich willkommen zu sagen
die sos sieg auf sand das ist das
anliegen wir besuchen wo man vielleicht
wirklich unangenehm findet wo manche
unterschrieben reparierte weil es einem
unternehmen
es gibt also kein heiliges wie möglich
sind dass du in euren glauben werden wir
jedoch wenig kleiner geht's immer mal
einen kaffee die chance sei nirgends
weil du es also ich habe der journalist
bespricht fragen die alle interessieren
aber die niemand zu stellen wagt dazu
gehören partnerschaft und sexualität
sind natürlich augen stimme auf robin
rehmann ist single
es sagt das verlangen nach sexualität
und zärtlichkeit drücke angesichts einer
chronischen erkrankung klar in den
hintergrund ist das problematisch war
mit der kommunikation
jetzt muss ich schon alles gehört
vielleicht haben ihn buchmarkt weil das
buch gefühlt aber ich glaube da danke
ich bin super
der chronische frank rieg das macht
eltern oma sollte megawatt ist mein job
hat unterbruchs grund einem buch das
passiert ab und zwei stunden habe es
immer schwierig es war fast 29 voll
friedlich früher habe er seine sorgen
und ängste überspielt und steht den
strahlemann gegeben
heute spricht er sie offen an teilt sein
schicksal in einem privaten videoblog
[Musik]
colitis ulcerosa sind wir schöne blume
ist leider nicht es ist eine schwere
unheilbar erkrankt
er scheut sich nicht seine abgründe
schonungslos offen zu legen
die waren ja wirklich bauchkrämpfen
die ich nicht in den griff bekomme
verliere meine sozialen kontakte ich war
einmal ein videos ständig motivieren von
wegen stechender sonne sehen
fühl mich nicht mehr so wirklich das
schaffen und ich habe das gefühl alles
zu verlieren
[Musik]
das ist daniel satz und den ersatz und
stuhldrang mit dem graben
sonderkontrollen dann ist gut weil wir
noch zeigen
wenn man nur in der 2
das ist immer wie wir haben wissen wo
sie eigentlich rentiert passieren und
tony und ich haben in basel besucht er
seinen besten freund
mit ihm waren in den ferien als ihnen
schwerer schub der krankheit drauf
januar gruppe um patrick bussinger
erlebte mit wie sich robin rehmann das
leben dramatisch verändert
er findet sein freund habe es ein
positives wesen trotzdem bewahren können
so positiv ist natürlich positiv auf
alle menschen nicht durch menschen gern
sieht wirklich kennen gosch auf menschen
zu und ich einfach gerne und dann wenn
du ab öffnet wird kukksi ich habe
erklärt wie die schule alle grüße
harmonie sowie hans necker immer vorrang
das drehbuch zum sage es hätte
mitarbeiter harmonika aber mehr sind
freunde sehr sehr wichtig dass ich nicht
viel
und dass jugendliche der stress
verbreitete mehr ist als ob sich als
sehr stressig jugend grad mehr
bild robin rehmann nicht erzählen nur
dies er habe als kind jeweils
bauchschmerzen bekommen wenn ihn die
probleme zu hause erdrückten dies als
einzige ursache für seine krankheit zu
sehen sei aber sicher unzulässig
hat das vielleicht nicht immer so die
heizung aber das ist doch gott sei dank
geschafft
[Musik]
früher war die rebellion sein
wirksamstes medikament als sänger einer
punkband riesig robin rehmann seine
sorgen und probleme von der seele
[Applaus]
zudem hinter die gegen uhr
tamara ist eine langjährige freundin und
angehende craniosacrale therapeutin bei
ihr sucht der chronisch kranke
entspannung ein bedürfnis über das er
noch vor wenigen jahren schallend
gelacht hätte ich habe keine politik
mehr
das heißt neben der ganze tektonischen
zündet sondern nur neue stück aladdin
schwer entzündet ich hab sogar nach der
darmspiegelung kortison aber fahrer wenn
ich das ganze kontinent als
provisorisches kamera vista gehört zu
einem kleinen freundeskreis den er seit
dem ausbruch der krankheit noch aufrecht
erhält also schwierig sie glaubt und
auch für mich das versteht dass ich mehr
energie habe gar nicht so für die
mancher wenig sie auf den typ der
entertainer die wahre geschichte erzählt
und machten durch kraft und energie in
die hand nehmen so hat das gefühl ich
muss wieder verzeichnen und so und
unterhalte und werde sich mit den leben
etwas nach
einmal mehr hole ich robin rehmann vom
spital um sich möglichst wenig bewegen
zu müssen fährt rollbrett seit tagen
plagen ihn schwere gliederschmerzen
die ärzte stellten eine entzündung an
den rippen fest
eine begleiterscheinung der colitis
ulcerosa
es ist ein ständiges auf und ab
auf phasen der erholung folgenschwere
rückfälle die krankheit diktiert sein
leben
trotzdem gibt muss ich sicher nicht ab
mit dem der diagnose der krankheit ihre
körper einfach nicht mitmacht
extrem schwierig hammergeil akzeptieren
und probiert man immer irgendwie wieder
ein werk findet das gilt gold der
zürcher muss die kortison dosis wieder
erhöhen
das medikament ist segen und fluch
zugleich
je mehr schluckt umso besser hat er die
chronische darmentzündung im griff
gleichzeitig leitete er aber unter
schweren nebenwirkungen die
schlaflosigkeit und
stimmungsschwankungen egal wie gesund
lebt egal was für medikamente er nimmt
robin reha wird immer ein patient
bleiben
das könne nur tragen wenn er seine
sorgen und probleme mit anderen teilen
sonst fresse in die krankheit auf aber
er wolle zuversichtlich bleiben und
weiter leben
trotzdem es ist geil schon vor was
sollen wir das extra gekauft ich sehe
das wirklich als entspannung und fühle
mich wohl wenn ich glaube und wenn das
noch und dann freue ich mich umso mehr
und da sich der stamm ist rang weiter
zum checker dass man mit gutem gewissen
als paar stunden auf dem sofa verbringen
mich stört vor dem motto sozi trägheit
durchbrechen
also sein bedeutet mir eine lücke still
star pause machen und so sondern immer
auf trab blieben verbesserte motivieren
mittlerweile finde ich das völlig haben
das jetzt einen schlagbaren jetzt fühle
ich darf aber ich hätte heute aber ist
der punkt mit bei dass es einfach nicht
diese naturell ist
du bist doch ein sehr kreativer sprudeln
der wilde mann eigentlich ist
das ist für mich keine belastung dort
besser zu verstehen dass ich das haben
aber jetzt wäre falsch da nicht drüber
zu reden weil ich das schuldig beruflich
neu bekommen dass die wissen was sie
erwartet und ich rede deutlich sagen es
ist kein weltuntergang das ist definitiv
nicht völlig neue erfahrung
[Musik]